hi guys add another question someone
asked me I'm doing keto but I have no
ketones in my urine so when I test
myself
it shows negative for ketones okay so
they wondered why that is let's talk
about that number one it could be that
you're burning up all your ketones see
the body is switching from glucose to
ketones as fuel so if you're burning all
them up it's not going to show up in the
urine and that usually happens after you
have adapted to keto a ketogenic diet
and also that you're have done it
probably more than two months but if
you've done it like under a month period
of time and it's not showing up this is
probably not the case because it takes a
while for you to become very efficient
and burn up all those ketones okay
number two are you doing in a minute
fasting if you're not you need to put
some videos down below but every time
you eat you spike insulin so the
combination of keto and intermittent
fasting is the best combination you need
to do that bite the bullet
but this because if you're eating six
meals a day with keto on all this fat
it's not going to work so you need to
throw this in there it's not reducing
the amount of eat that you eat it's
reducing the frequency that you eat
number three this is interesting because
I'll ask people I'll say are you getting
enough sleep and they're saying yes are
you tired
no and so I'm pulling a string I said
how many hours sleep you get they go six
and a half I said well what do you do
during the day I work all day long I
push myself I says what would happen if
you were just to sit there and just not
do any work
I'd fall asleep okay good well chances
are you're not getting enough sleep in
other words a lot of people don't
realize that their body is tired they're
just pushing through it not putting an
attention on it but they're actually
tired because they're kind not getting
enough sleep okay so what I recommend
and I have done this several times go to
bed early or squeeze that another hour
hour and a half of sleep stop watching
the news especially the news and try to
take a nap but you you need about seven
and a half to eight hours to really
maximize not just fat-burning
and improve your ketosis and your
metabolism but also just to improve your
recovery after your workouts you'll see
more change that little change will make
a huge difference I take the sleep baby
before bed maybe you want to take two of
them before bed and then you add the
calcium lactate with that the
combination of calcium lactate and sleep
aid work really good calcium lactate
just gives that little extra push to get
an asleep faster and then not too much
protein some people are consuming way
too much we want three to six ounces and
we want to make sure you're not snacking
this protein protein it will act as a
stimulant and prevent you from sleeping
and number four exercise in the fasting
period in the other videos I told you to
exercise in the eating window okay
alright before you're eating and right
after eating what I'm suggesting if you
don't have a blood sugar issue and you
should just try this to see if you can
do it work out in the fasting period so
let's say you ate at 12 noon and you
have another your dinner at five or six
you would fast in the early morning or
if you work if you eat a breakfast and
your last meal is it let's say two and
you worked out at six or seven I kind of
like to do that I think you're going to
see a lot more change because you're
gonna you're going to enhance the growth
hormone factor when you work out and see
more change in the ketones in your urine
okay go ahead and try these and put put
in your comments below the changes that
occur hi guys hey listen I created a
pretty amazing evaluation quiz down
below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause so take the quiz now and
we'll send you a report